You can't come off of what you're doing.
So, let's say uh we generate the energy.
Okay, there there's that. I feel his
unification and then I try I come out of
what I'm doing. Do you see what I'm
doing? You get what I'm saying here?
Okay. So, we we're here.
We generate.
And what I would recommend is that you
barely move this thing.
I'm barely moving it to me train train
to to me actually trained I I feel his
center already. Okay. I'm just
confirming it with the tiny bit of
movement. So tiny right there. Okay. You
understand? So don't you're not trying
to throw him like that. You saw how he
linked. Okay.
Okay,
I'm just trying to that force is on us.
We have communed and I'm just moving
that thing ever so tiny. See his head?
Okay.
Okay. Now let for for you
what will happen is
that when they feel that they they will
react against that's what people do.
Okay. And if I keep what I'm doing the
adhesion gets tighter. So watch the
watch that the the the
yong value got like higher as we go.
Okay. So
you might experience that. So meaning
that if I go and there's his yong value
and it triggers me, I'm going to lose
it. I'm going to link. You understand?
So his his increase as I start to
manipulate his center
should make feel that value getting
higher here and that gives you the
center much easier as long as you don't
go into the reactionary cycle. Okay.